resident evil is celebrating the big two
five this year
so it makes perfect sense to take a look
back at some of the best villains from
the series and their wildest
transformations
is it too early to put lady dimitrisco
on the list
maybe but just know she's definitely
here in spirit
we're going to continue celebrating the
resident evil anniversary with another
video reminiscing on all of its gruesome
history
so make sure to subscribe so you don't
miss it
at this point resident evil and albert
wesker go hand in hand as he was not
only one of the first main villains of
the story
but had lived on throughout the series
in numerous titles
wesker was on a mission to become a god
of a new world
except he wanted to create that world
from the ashes of our own
he often worked in the shadows but when
he did show up he carried a calm and
collected nature
that we learned to be more like the calm
before a storm
his transformation in resident evil 5
also showed us how powerful he really
was since he was still in full control
of himself after
infecting himself with auroboros he
mutated
and fused with the metal around him to
create massive deadly arms to combine
with his strength
however the lava boss pulls a fast one
on wesker to give chris and cheva a
chance to finish the fight
although if you ask me he totally dodged
those rockets
[Music]
in resident evil 7 it's pretty easy to
say that the whole baker family was
definitely a problem
but the true terror was evelyn she was
an escape test subject who had the means
of infecting others and controlling
their minds
we see her as a young girl for most of
the story and deep down she's just
looking for a family to love
however since she was genetically
engineered and raised in captivity
she was pretty unstable and was creating
her family by force
as we saw from the bakers eventually
ethan is able to stop evelyn's mind
control
and we see her old and withered form
horrifically melt away
before she completely consumes the house
being stuck in that room with her face
is forever burned into my memory soon
the house is too small and evelyn bursts
out and turns into a massive
mold monster that requires a very
special gun to take down
once and for all
osman sadler's success with controlling
las plagueis spelled
nothing but disaster for the world as
the parasite was genetically modified
and then
turned into a bioweapon not to mention
sadler's success in also creating a cult
other horrifying monsters and basically
all of the perfect pieces
for a skin crawling transformation
seeing that eye come out of his mouth at
the start of the transformation
will haunt me forever the massive
spider-like creature
dangles the human form of saddler around
while his head
whips in flails off of his snake neck
seriously
nightmare fuel
good thing aydah was able to toss this
in rpg to squash this bug
alexia ashford created and wielded the t
veronica virus and used it to unleash
three transformations on us even her
very first form sent wesker running and
leaving chris to do the dirty work
alexia's transcendence down the stairs
engulfed in flames to reach her first
form is pretty
epic her second form bursts from her
first with long spiky arms piercing from
her body
her face and eyes becoming stretched and
distorted and large root-like tentacles
swinging away at you
and finally her third form lets her rise
from the roots of rot she was sitting on
and you have to fight her in bug form
which is
nothing a good old linear launcher can't
handle
william birkin was one of the lead
scientists behind the gnt viruses
and had eventually turned against
umbrella after he found out they had no
plans on advancing him through the
organization
in his last ditch effort william injects
himself with the last remaining samples
of the g-virus
and sends us through five increasingly
disgusting transformations
his first transformation is just a
portion of his upper body
and you can tell he still has a slight
grasp on himself for a short time
as he loses control we get to his next
transformation where he sprouts a brand
new mutant head while slicing through a
t-zero zero like
butter by phase three all that's left is
a mirror imprint of william's face
and we're left with a massive forearm
creature covered in eyes
teeth and claws and somehow it gets
worse
william continues to mutate with a
creepy jawless skull protruding out of
his heap of eyes and teeth
as he even starts to crawl and climb by
the final phase
the mutation was out of control with
william being nothing but a mass of
bones consuming an entire train car
that eventually goes down in flames
we all may be familiar with albert
wesker but there was also another evil
mastermind in the family
his sister alex wesker after albert's
death alex followed in his footsteps to
not only avenge him
but to surpass him however her plan
backfired as her own fear got in the way
and made her mutate into a hideous form
that she covered with robes out of shame
her new mission was to take over natalya
no matter the cost
which sends her into a transformative
rage as she morphs into an insanely
creepy
backwards crawling nightmare the
elongated spine
always freaks me out but barry's
one-liners still crack me up
you can't have her
alex eventually meets the same fate as
her brother in the form of a missile
flying from a chopper but in another
ending she does transfer her
consciousness to natalya
successfully hmm
[Music]
derek simmons goes full animal sinus in
leon's re-6 campaign after being
injected by
surprise surprise another genetically
modified virus
he hops from mutant forms that look like
dogs horses
giraffes and dinosaurs while also
morphing back into his human form to be
sure to give leon
a chance to throw some hands
by the end of the very long fight derek
has mutated into his largest form yet as
a giant bug that's consuming
nearby zombies in the process with a
trusty rpg in hand
one final blast sends derrick off the
edge of a helipad and down to his death
where he is impaled
but interestingly he dies in his human
form
those are our picks but let us know
which other enemies from the resident
evil series have scarred you for life
do you want to see other roundups of
transformations from protagonists or
side characters
then let us know in the comments in the
meantime
we've got you covered on all things
resident evil on our channel
from the latest news on village and even
a full explainer on the timeline itself
thanks for watching and of course leave
a like subscribe and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
you